hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 7 vigilante video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet there was the twist of all
twists at the end just to start things
off I will say that the vigilante
character is not the Prometheus
character it's not the same person
underneath the mask for those that are
wondering because some of you might know
who vigilante is from the comics we saw
him in this episode but just for the
people that don't read comics I don't
want to spoil that upfront but if you're
not sure really watch the last couple of
episodes
I thought they've done a good job
teasing a certain character reveal four
vigilante without beating you in the
face with it
so let's just do top 10 WTF is a big
twist at the end which is actually
really cool so a whole bunch of stuff
going on and we know about the arrow
100th episode so I'll talk about that at
the end of the video too because there's
a whole bunch of stuff happening around
that in two weeks so number 10 meet
vigilante the newest vigilante dropping
bodies in Star City and there was an
impressive body count in this episode
but you have to remember that he's
gunning people down so there's gonna be
a ton of bodies but they've actually
been about 6 different versions of the
character in the comics they actually
flashed a picture of original art by
George Perez for his version of the
vigilante character who if you know who
that is in the comics then you know who
he is on the TV show they're sticking
pretty close to his origin and they kind
of teased that in this episode so number
9 you haven't been pushed over the edge
like vigilante tells Oliver you may have
lost people but you haven't reached the
point that I've reached vigilantes
family was gunned down punisher style so
he has a Punisher type origin story
where he goes from being this upstanding
member of the community to being a
vigilante that just guns down criminals
indiscriminately which kind of dovetails
with you know number eight the dark
versus light path so Oliver has this big
existential crisis in the episode where
he's like maybe nothing we've been doing
is working I don't I don't understand
like should we just start dropping
bodies again what's the deal
but what would normally be a Felicity
scene where she's like hey you know do
things the right way is actually the
Susan Williams character that tells him
to chill out just a little bit and just
stay the course like you're doing it the
right way
do not turn to the dark side Anakin
Skywalker so number seven also happening
in the flashbacks to almost the exact
same story Kovar gives him the same
version of that speech where he's like
good evil it's all relative the Bratva
made a deal with me to get a portion of
my profits that's the only reason they
let you in the organization so flashback
Oliver just like had his whole world
flipped upside down so now it seems like
he's never gonna get revenge but
obviously they just want things that
seem really terrible so that he has to
climb out of another hole or climb off
of another Island so to speak that the
real big twist you know number six is
the Tiana's mother like the person who
he's trying to kill Cove r4 is working
for Kovar what a sweet woman you
probably know her daughter tiana and
flashback oliver just like craps his
pants like oh my god so the whole point
of the flashbacks like all these scenes
is just to make Kovar seem invincible
and untouchable like this insurmountable
goal so it's just gonna be that much
more satisfying when oliver takes him
down if he's able to take him down by
the end of the season so i know it's a
long ways off I'm not expecting it but
it would be pretty badass
if Prometheus turned out to be Kovar or
someone connected to Coe far you do get
the sense that he has a larger role to
play because he's such a big figure in
the flashbacks so it would seem weird if
flashback Oliver is able to defeat him
and then we never hear from him or his
organization again usually the
flashbacks sync up with modern-day a
little bit so just expect that kovar
plot to get teased out the same way they
tease out Prometheus and now the
vigilante character speaking of
Prometheus number five Quentin comes
clean to Thea he knows he's been
blacking out but he has no idea what's
going on and is convinced someone's
trying to pin the Prometheus murders on
him I think that whole speech was just
to throw water on the idea that Quentin
is being mind-controlled when he's
blacked out like he's not a secret ninja
without knowing about it
so there's some other character who's
prometheus they are just messing with
Quentin
because as Oliver finds out number four
prometheus knows who he is
meaning that he knows about team arrow
knowing that Quentin is connected to it
all so number three
team arrow versus vigilante round one
they was that awesome trick shot where
he bull's-eyes Artemis's
arrow he's able to get away pretty
easily till round two where he actually
gets the drop on team arrow as they're
trying to lay a trap for him so like the
whole point here like the fact that he
gets away without Oliver being able to
unmask him just lets you know that it's
gonna be a much bigger plotline like
they're not just gonna unmask him right
away and that'll be the end of it and if
you know who he is on the show then you
can start to guess that maybe he'll find
out all of her secret before Oliver
learns his secret and it'll lead to some
really fun times so we'll just go ahead
and say it's okay to talk about who he
really is on the TV show if you've read
the comics or if you know that twist but
just use a spoiler tag in the comments
when you're talking about it but what
I'm expecting is is that his storyline
will kind of collide with Prometheus's
storyline relatively quickly like before
the mid-season finale where we'll
probably get a big reveal about
vigilantes character and Prometheus's
character at the same time but they are
two different people so number one WTF
though this is really fun I really like
this twist Artemis is working with
prometheus
so it's a very sports mastery twist for
those of you that didn't watch Young
Justice
Artemis on that show had a different
origin story from Artemis on arrow so
young justice Artemis is actually the
daughter of two villains one of them is
sports master so her whole arc on that
TV show was about not following in her
parents footsteps like even though you
come from evil that doesn't mean that
you have to be evil so on arrow you can
guess that that might have something to
do with Artemis as well but you can see
that she's so upset about Oliver not
being able to help her parents that
that's probably what drove her to start
working with Prometheus so I don't think
that prometheus is her father I think
that it's just someone who has beef
against team arrow and Oliver
specifically so the enemy of my enemy is
my friend
thus Artemis and Prometheus are friends
temporarily but let me know what you
guys thought of the episode I thought it
moved pretty well so a little bit about
that though the arrow hundredth episode
this is separately from Laurel coming
back in
second half of the season don't really
know how that's gonna happen but they
did explain a lot about the hundredth
episode most of which will take place in
a dream sequence where Oliver didn't get
on the Queen's Gambit so like he has a
completely different life they kind of
imply that there is no green arrow so
you just have fun seeing what star city
is like what those characters are like
had they gone down a different path
so like Laurel is still alive it looks
like she and Oliver are getting ready to
get married then Oliver starts to notice
little things are off so he you know he
comes to the realization that he's in an
artificial reality that has something to
do with the dominators because of course
it happens during the third night of the
four night crossover so we don't know
how long we're gonna spend in that dream
sequence during the arrow episode but
I'm guessing at least like half of the
episode is gonna be this arrow what if
they actually did the same thing on
Batman the Animated Series where Batman
enters hypnosis and he experiences this
reality where his parents were not gun
downed in Crime Alley
so everything's weird he's not the
Batman until he slowly starts to realize
that what he's experiencing is not real
so that's probably the way it's gonna go
down with Oliver but that episode isn't
dropping for another two weeks so next
week arrow is on break but I think the
other shows are still happening I know
the flash for sure has a new episode
next week so I think arrow is the only
one that's on break so I'll just post
updates on the schedule as I post new DC
videos but there is new legends tomorrow
night Jonah Hex is coming back and
there's a big change in the legends
schedule in the second half of the
season so what they're doing is is when
everything comes back in the spring
legends is going to air after the flash
at 9:00 p.m. on Tuesday nights so it's
going to be Supergirl on Mondays than
the flash and legends one right after
the other and then arrow on Wednesdays
so there will be no DC TV shows on
Thursdays anymore it'll be Monday
Tuesday Wednesday which makes Tuesday
really interesting because I try to do
videos for shield every once in a while
so we'll figure the schedule out it's
not gonna happen for a while but just a
reminder a new round of the DC giveaway
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just a $20 Amazon gift
card so I'll announce the winner when I
post my legends video tomorrow where you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for the trailer
for the four night crossover and you can
click here for the flash killer frost
trailer for next week's flash episode
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight